so if you're looking into homeschooling
there are a couple different ways to go about it
and one of those ways is unschooling
that's just a method of homeschooling
um unschooling
pretty basically is the idea of not doing any sort of
like institutionalized learning
curriculum learning or workbook type learning
the hypothesis is that kids learn from their environment and like
it's a much more freeform way of learning or teaching
um it's not something that I necessarily do or adhere to
but I definitely see other people who do it and love it and get a lot out of it
um but my family actually does a hybrid of curriculum and unit study
homeschooling
which means for certain subjects
I have set curriculum and curriculum books
and we follow along on the schedule
and then when we need to shake things up
we do a unit study
which is basically accomplishing all of your core subject requirements